welcome back to visual effects artist
react we have an incredible delicious
selection of Clips the teenager using
blender in their bedroom energy is real
high in this episode
this is ape
you've seen Tom Cruise's cool stunts
they did for real well today we're gonna
really break down how real they actually
are
that's so cool dude now this is pretty
high up there and a recreation of the
across the spider-verse trailer using
only Lego what let's get into it let's
get into it now
yeah
imagine time space under the Mastery of
man so someone had suggested some of the
Crazy Train effects from Lone Ranger and
I was watching the scenes they are
amazing but this recommended video
popped up and recently the YouTube
algorithms have been a little weird it's
been giving us some some wacky things I
was like blender train crash animation
short film
sure oh no let's just check it out this
is gonna be great strong working title
oh this is from langdon's animation
wheelhouse dude this is bringing back
shades of Polar Express all day the
ticket scene this is Peak nephew
animation right now it's pretty great
oh my God
[Laughter]
Oh that's oh
my God oh my goodness oh my God
it's like The Last of Us yeah this must
be the train crash that the title
foreshadowed yeah I think so wow wow
it delivered oh no we're never gonna see
Santa
[Laughter]
deleted scene Polar Express
oh my God no this is Apes yet
oh feathers
I think he's good
God what a what an animation like wow
his sense of rhythm of like Classic
Hollywood destruction is like so dialed
in he like he knows exactly the pacing
like that Michael Bay editing style I
think the title can maybe use some work
but I will say it's so funny because you
go in expecting like okay it's gonna be
a train and then it's gonna crash it's a
test it's an animation test and it's
just a full story of this guy
discovering he's alone on a train like
this is not a test this is totally just
a full-on short film like these types of
super intense like hyper slo-mo shots
it's very I don't know like I would say
it's like Michael Bay but it's also a
little Bollywood yes totally totally
blender Bollywood who knew that that was
the what I was waiting for this guy's
great yeah I'm hooked when something's
labeled as basic as like blender train
crash animation test and it has like
millions of views you know it's going to
be special that's we Landon fernald
furnald yeah Landon fantastic landed
well are we gonna watch The Lone Ranger
now or this is we're actually not
watching The Lone Ranger yeah whatever
right yeah well I'm gonna say that for
another episode what's up everybody
Bessie today's sponsor you guys heard us
talk about him a lot we love their shoes
but I have a big surprise and new
updates for a lot of people in the
studio today Jordan Coleman you like
besties right yeah I love bessies you
love their shoes uh yeah that's why I
wear them to work out all the time so my
feet don't stink well I guess what what
if I told you the bestie is expanding
everything you know and love about the
sneakers is now in a jacket especially
the overcast jacket made from the same
Diamond text materials as your shoes
keeping you cool in the summer and warm
in the winter this is dime attached yes
it is fully waterproof prove that pull
out on me do it do it
not even wet not even wet it just
bounces off not that though ignore the
ground ignore the ground the jacket is
dry Hey Dean I heard you're going to
Portland in a little bit and it rains a
lot is that true uh well I've never been
there so I wouldn't know well I heard it
rains a lot and Bessie has a new
all-waterproof jacket guess what in case
you can't fit all your personal items in
these waterproof Pockets the shoreline
fanny pack which basically has all the
same features as the shoes and this
jacket built into a Fannie backpack
fully waterproof made out of diamond
text it's gonna be like a fully
waterproof dude wearing all my bestie
stuff frog man once they make pants we
are frogman we can become the full
Frogman all right well if you're going
to Portland soon or you just live in a
place where it rains a lot go to
vesti.com Florida crew and get 15 off
your order they got the bags they got
the jackets and of course they got the
shoes you know and love now let's get
back to that react episode
[Music]
Okay so we've seen these Mission
Impossible movies if there's a whole
conversation today about practical
versus CGI and you know these Mission
Impossible movies are like hey he did
this for real and it's kind of funny
when you watch the final shot in the
movie because there's still tons of
visual effects happening in fact some
more than others where like some are
pretty true to the stunt and some are
kind of like well did you really have to
do this done yeah all the CG you put in
there and I think it'd be kind of cool
to take a quick peek at some of those
huge shots
so the first one here is his big plane
stun
I mean it's pretty cool yeah this is
super yeah
that's so awesome man we've all thought
about it
wow man so this one is like the truest
one yeah this is his truest shot of the
ones we're gonna look at today because
this is like a wire pin out oh yeah so
it is it's all legit that's the full
background yeah but you can see that
like look it's just raw there might be a
little bit of background augmentation
here and there if the paint out like a
semi truck or some crew but I'm pretty
sure that like most of that takeoff is
legit dude and the wires aren't even
like that helpful yeah it doesn't look
like they're it's like they fed it out
the door and they're like just here wrap
this around your waist so that one's
pretty legit like how Okay out of ten
like how would you rate how real this
stunt is second nine I am nine nine five
yeah it's like everything you're
watching it's like yeah that happened
yeah they did it
the next film has this HALO jump
sequence and when I saw this in the
theaters I even though I had heard you
know all the hype he did it for real I
was watching it and going hmm he did it
for real eh
[Music]
this is all legit now I mean yeah the
camera guy jumped with Tom Cruise and
they had to hit this point I remember
hearing about this how they had to get
to that exact distance and pull Focus
wow wow pressure that but now it feels
like we're in a green screen Studio
so yeah this is CG and this is I guess
picked up the real take stitched yeah
because this looks like it's pretty real
again but like that entire Cloud
sequence with like the lightning and
then getting Zapped and the tumbling I
was just like like obviously you could
have copped some lightning in but even
still it feels a little cartoony felt a
little it's a little off yeah obviously
we see they did perform a ton of these
things in the air and they are all
stitched together using visual effects I
mean this is rad without the storm I
feel tension you know I don't think they
needed the storm for attention I think
they could have just skydived so out of
10 once again how much of the shot was
you know done for real if you cut after
this take here and like you had this
crazy live single take here and then
it's like cool now let's cut and go to
the next sequence that's real I would
give it a nine but if you count the
whole thing with the CG storm and the CG
parachute and all that stuff it falls
down to level six yeah and and I would
honestly argue you know in the attempt
to do the Warner they use a digital
double to stitch between sections of the
runner and immediately again it triggers
that part of your brain because it's not
perfect and if it's not perfect you you
are triggered to be on guard and that
calls into question all of it so for me
it reduced it to a seven yeah because
the moment you see a composited CG storm
in the shot I'm like how do I know it's
real now like you've just purposely
shown me something that's fake if that's
not true so if I'm to believe that he
really quote unquote did this like it
puts it all into Jeopardy and so on one
hand it is impressive but ultimately it
does kind of mess with the presentation
just because you stop thinking about oh
this is all real it's like oh at this
point anything goes yeah yeah it may as
well not be have you guys seen Point
Break no it's Patrick Swayze just just
for reference can we just pull up the
skydiving from Point Break All right so
we're talking about like high stakes
skydiving they're making their escape
here yeah okay what
[Laughter]
I can't not make the sound
oh God
yes that's so cool oh man what no
parachute dude freaking gonna shoot it
this is sick wait I can't believe I've
never seen this this is intense he's
just got a handgun yeah
that's amazing don't you hate when you
think you're safe please
sneaks up behind you with a gun
finally Freedom oh here they come
this is a robbery come on give me all
your money
he left my wallet on the airplane I mean
this is still pretty convincing from a
storytelling standpoint this is hitting
all the marks 100 I'm not doubting that
they're following at any point this
close-up's like sure it's again there's
you know they got a lot of wind they're
on a ladder yeah they're on a ladder
with a leaf blower it doesn't matter
because like all the real shots of them
skydiving uh that's a little janky oh
damn
I mean there's a stunt right there that
hurts yeah that looks like it hurt for
sure oh you didn't make it that guy
burning man right
let's get some Bill and Ted we just like
just opened the 10 foot on the ground
and like crawl inside of it without
assembling it oh what a party
what a cool scene it's a great scene
it's a great sequence dude this this
moment right here he has to psych
himself up he's like what am I gonna do
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna jump out
this airplane I love it that shot's so
Grand and this one like they hold it for
a long time and then you see everybody
like they get everybody in the frame
there yeah it's great this is what I'm
saying like it it functions really
really well the party comes up to him
and like he actually have the camera guy
first person like put his hand out like
he's coming closer and like at the end
he reaches out and hits them you'll see
and they keep that I love that they keep
that yeah that's great and it probably
was like a legitimate protective move
where he's like yeah he's trying to do
it yeah it makes you wonder like there's
no giant airplane there's no crazies
costumes there's no storm there's no
city underneath doesn't just make you
feel the same thrill as Mission
Impossible or does Mission Impossible
make you feel more thrilled this is more
this is more almost significantly this
is more threat like these of course yeah
these these long lines close-ups you
know what they're doing but yeah it
never feels cartoony at all and that's
what pulls me out as a viewer because
again it's like any time you're tackling
real danger we saw it in the flash the
baby shower scene the minute that you
are no longer connected to the
characters because they're not real or
what's happening around them isn't real
you don't care anymore and it's you know
that's just the reality of it so this
still feels real and therefore I'm still
invested well one more we got one more
oh this one yeah I'm familiar with this
jump
that's so cool dude now this is pretty
high up there this was the big one that
I heard so much about before we shot it
it's like oh my gosh taking a motorcycle
off a big jump and parachuting is super
cool and how perfect have they found the
the perfect Mountain slope that's the
thing for this you can tell it's CG
background though it's like it just
doesn't hit when you got an actor
looking at CG background can't wait to
go off the CG jump even though he did it
for real he jumped off a real jump he
didn't jump off like natural rock
formations yeah like look how much
engineering is going into that like all
that scaffolding and everything it's so
much stuff everything until he goes off
the Jump is fake but then it's all
really again it looks like because that
looks like the same scene once he's
falling it's real again yeah so once you
like look down over the dip that's all
legit again the moment of like the GoPro
on his parachute where he opens it he's
going oh I'm like straining against it
that's a real Moment Like that's me
that's where the money is you know
that's why you want to do it this one
scores higher for me for sure than the
than the other skydiving one even with
all the CG even with all the CG because
that CG exists as landscape surrounding
for the legitimate wonder that is not
manipulated and doesn't take you out of
it at the end of the day he's passing by
CG but the CG is not being used as him
like that is the difference to me so I
give this one eight and a half yeah I
give it an eight yeah yeah it's it's up
there because once again it's really
just coming down to is the CG being used
to replace what he did you know what I'm
saying like I don't question much about
this shot you don't watch them go did he
really go off that jump so I asked for
people to tell us about some bad fire
effects after we did that one episode we
talked about fire and this one was
mentioned by multiple people in years
from 2008 mirrors what you see in the
mirror happens to you in real life
oh no is this in his imagination or is
this happening in real life
motion with stock assets is tough
there's impossible it's an impossible
ask because again it's like anytime you
have a source with fire that Source
moves the fire that's already been
emitted doesn't move with it but the new
source does and inherits its velocity so
if I'm moving the fire around you're
seeing this lift it up but these stock
fire assets they're just going up you'll
get motion blur left and right but the
source and everything above it will move
together and inherit no velocity and
just look really weird watch
my hands are really on fire so good
believe it or not it looks so good you
know like the shot almost works at the
very beginning he's not moving too much
and the compositing color wise is
actually pretty good like it feels like
the film everything on film they got
nice colors it's like I feel like the
film is like okay this is working this
is working and they get to the later
sequence they're just like oh no they're
just going he's just going he's kicking
his camera no please now it's like now
you need to cut to the stunt person get
out of there yeah yeah now it's now it's
getting oh now and then the legs
one thing that really was bugging me too
is also just like the super hard crisp
turbulence displacement yeah the heat
displacement of like the air bending
from the temperature is like so much
more I don't know blurry it's blurrier
that's for sure you see it rise with the
fire the smoke moving with it so you
just have to see all the weird smoke and
black particles yeah black particles
when he drops to his knees the entire
plume of smoke just goes down with him
oh no no oh no oh no oh no
oh that's the artist yeah yeah and of
course there's no there's no um
there's no light being emitted onto him
at all there's no Shadows being you're
right zero light zero fire light on let
me put zero fire light on them it's just
so funny because then the director is
probably like no but the reason there's
no light on him is because
it's all in this imagination it's not
really happening he's not really on fire
it was supposed to It's supposed
supposed to look kind of fake you know
like the flash
it's supposed to look like that all
right we're not done oh one more not
this one's not fire at all this one
might not make it onto the YouTube
version this might be a website only
thing if you want to see what Nico's
talking about head over to Corridor
digital.com
have you guys seen across the spider
verse no not yet I can't but I wanted to
no this is the trailer for Spider-Man
across the spider-verse and I want to
watch this first to set the tone a
little bit who Do You Think You Are
so much work dude yeah I've seen that
the whole movie I was thinking that 30
minutes in I was like okay that's enough
stop it Yep looks super cool obviously a
lot going on very visually demanding
what would you say if I told you
that there were a team of animators in
Canada who recreated this trailer shot
for shot with Lego Lego what no way who
do you think you are really this was
before the movie came out the trailer
had just dropped and this team went and
rebuilt it is this this is easy Lego oh
yeah
still this is insane I mean you guys
nailed it immediately you know it's CG
it's not real Lego and this was all done
in blender which is impressive enough
but what would you say
if I told you don't don't don't just
please stop that this team of animators
was one 14 year old boy his name is
Preston mutanga
are you serious blender animation
tutorial train crash one 14 year old boy
after school made this in a month out of
Toronto Canada uh Langdon wow not my
friend anymore
Preston has moved into Sam's Hall it is
absolutely mind-blowing and I wasn't the
only one who felt this way because Lord
and Miller caught wind of this after
their trailer released and immediately
reached out to him to work on the actual
film having no idea he was 14. they find
out he's 14 their minds are blown and
Preston actually did the Lego scene from
the film wow and it is a great scene man
wow he killed it and he did it after
hours so he'd come home from school and
work on across the spider verse I feel
so inadequate
what a talent man it's so inspiring to
just go and do it do the thing and like
it's what you see with a shamuk is
another great example of someone just
doing the thing they love putting it
online for free to Showcase their
talents and end up doing Luke Skywalker
deep fix for the actual show and it's
like what a cool time to be alive as an
artist where you can showcase your work
directly to the people who need to see
it yeah that's great super cool more
than anything it's a call to just go and
do the thing that's on your mind just go
and pursue it because you never know
who's watching thanks to all of your
comments I have so many clips that I can
pull from for this episode but these
guys don't so these suggestions that
they can add to their list because I'm
prepared and they need some more I
literally have none I literally have
none help me are you subscribed Sam
don't be like Sam you guys ai's coming
to pick your job and your viewing habits
so make sure you subscribe